aburridos,
como leones lacónicos al lado de gacelas a medio comer,
con labios sangrientos...
"Los EE.UU. y el Cuerpo Afroamericano" aparece en el National Geographic.
Aprobó su examen de conducir en el Departamento de Vehículos.
Se pavoneó con un movimiento de Fortnite
y entró para terminar el papeleo,
verdadera alegría y calma calculada mientras lo grabé con mi iPhone,
el baile de la victoria de alguien que ha logrado empatar.
Merece la victoria, pero solo tiene 16 años
y no es capaz de dejar su cuerpo completamente libre.
Cuando él tenía tres años,
me esposaron en el centro de Oakland.
Cinco minutos antes, estaba estacionado ilegalmente.
Ahora, estaba en la parte trasera de una patrulla, contemplando mi muerte,
aquí, a 15 minutos de donde estaba mi hijo
quién esperaba a que su papá lo recogiera de la escuela en 18 minutos.
No habían cámaras de bolsillo que grabasen este momento.
A los 16 años, aprendí muchas grandes palabras
para el examen de acceso a la universidad.
pero en ese momento se me habían olvidado todas.
En la patrulla, mi piel era lo único que hablaba.
Esto es lo que sé:
me estacioné en un carril de autobús entre Avenida 12 y Broadway,
corrí a un cajero automático.
Tomé el dinero mientras que una patrulla se detuvo detrás de mí.
Dije, "Perdón, culpa mía",
con un aire de convicción afroamericana.
Él esperó hasta que estuve en el auto y luego encendió la sirena,
se llevó de mi licencia y en la mano tenía su arma,
volvió dos minutos después, sacó el arma,
llegó otra patrulla con cuatro agentes,
me tumbé boca abajo, con las manos en la espalda, esposado.
Estaba furioso y humillado hasta que me dio miedo y tristeza.
Inhalé como si fuera mi último aliento antes de morir.
Pensé en cuánto esperaría mi hijo antes de darse cuenta
de que ya no venía su papá.
Creí que su último recuerdo de mí, apenas formado,
sería la historia de cómo nunca fui a recogerlo.
Intenté despedirme de él telepáticamente.
El silencio no me trajo paz.
La calma hizo difícil el reposo.
En el vacío la ira proliferaba como moho en el fondo musgoso de mis pensamientos,
un hongo crecía en la raíz de mis tentativas de libertad.
Estoy libre de todo excepto del desprecio,
el espíritu de un civil desarmado en tiempos de disturbios civiles,
ninguna paz, solo los falsetes de Marvin Gaye,
curvados como las alas rotas de un gorrión,
compitiendo contra las sirenas frívolas,
cantando con la policía.
Pareció que había una orden contra un tipo de Richmond,
y cuando el agente llamó a la central, no oyó el nombre "Marc Joseph",
sino "Mike Johnson".
Después conté siete autos y 18 agentes en la esquina,
como una manada alrededor de una pila de carne.
Por la gracia de Dios, no me echaron a los leones ese día.
Generosamente, el primer agente se aseguró de multarme
por haberme aparcado en un carril de autobús,
antes de liberarme.
Mi hijo tiene 16 años.
Tiene una licencia para conducir en esta ciudad hueca,
suficiente cuerpo para sustituirme.
Tengo la barba canosa,
y dice la verdad.
Él puede abrirse paso a través del tráfico en la era de vehículos autónomos.
La gente dice "el discurso",
como si pasara solo una vez,
como si me borraran la memoria
y el Internet estuviese descompuesto,
como si no leyera el nombre del mártir de hoy,
como si no amara a mi hijo lo suficiente
para decirle, "hermano, me importa un pepino tus derechos.
Tu misión es regresar a casa.
Sobrevive para contarme la historia, hijo.
Vuelve a casa".
La charla de hoy ocurre en mi mente
mientras él toma la autopista y Marvin Gaye suena en la radio.
Uso los zapatos de mi hijo,
y la tonada en mi cabeza es la despedida que casi nunca le dije,
un adiós tanto como un réquiem,
un beso, el olor de su cuello,
la longitud de una revelación
y una solicitud que sube al cielo amable
sin nunca dejar la tierra.
Mi dolor es una línea de walking bass,
un estribillo, la tensión aplacada contra la línea de bajo que disminuye.
Escuchen, no es para ser romántico,
sino para presentar un escenario plausible para el momento existencial.
Conducir como afroamericano es una experiencia en sí misma.
Pregúntenselo a Marvin.
Quizá no es la razón por la que cantan como un ángel,
pero tiene que ver con la manera en la que el cielo les guía la voz.
El chico que conduce y el agente en el espejo retrovisor
es una montaña rusa o la muerte.
Cuando se da "el discurso" a un chico negro,
se reza que sea parte de aquella fracción que sobreviva.
Le revelan la frecuencia de su despedida telepática,
canalizan el amor prolongado en el registro superior de Marvin
debajo de su gorra.
Lo mejor de la música negra
es un agujero negro que ha explotado
respondiendo a la llamada de los EE.UU. en su peor momento.
Nos derriban pero sigue la música,
oscura, al igual que alquitrán o tabaco
o el algodón en el agua fangosa.
Vuelve a casa, hijo.
Como un amor supremo, un dios en forma de amor,
un amor que prevalece,
plumas para la ascensión angelical de los muertos inquietos,
como un tema para un hombre afligido,
o un chico de 16 años, libre de cometer errores y superarlos,
de crecer a partir de ellos,
santo, santo, piedad, piedad de mí,
piedad,
piedad.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)